la démarche a peut-être un peu moins
fluide qu'avant mais l'amour du sport
est toujours aussi fort emilien valait
essaie de jouer au tennis tous les jours
comme celle de ce sport sa réponse des
armes par sa simplicité
même temps je suis avant tout comme
comme seul moi je suis jeune je plane à
mada il a transmis sa passion du sport à
ses cinq enfants en particulier à denis
et keita qui viennent échanger des
balles avec lui inler perdu un petit peu
à cause qui est parfait d'activité
pendant un an et demi mais l'eau sale sa
der vigueur ça me rend heureux ça me
rend un motif aussi parce que c'est pas
donné à tout le monde de pouvoir jouer
avec son père rendu à 91 ans mais ça me
donne surtout la chance de le battre
il n'y a pas eu comme batteur il a
d'ailleurs remporté des tournois en
floride pour les 70 ans et plus
monsieur valais a d'ailleurs choisi sa
résidence parce que les vingt terrains
de tennis dehors mais les partenaires se
font rares ça ne l'arrêtent pas renoncé
à jouer seulement le jeu que je me suis
fait j'adore ça je 1h30 2h je préfère ça
à bâle il a toujours eu du succès dans
le sport beau tennis mais aussi à la
balle molle au ballon balai et même à
des tournois à télé qui jusqu'à ce que
l'ancien menuisier ce coup droit au
travail et à la royal victoria
et puis
je ne change que j'étais à l'hôpital et
je me suis le mieux réagi ces deux
petits joyaux ils s'appuient beaucoup
fait que je me charge du majeur plus
proche puis un peu de l'index c'est
comme ça que je joue depuis plusieurs
années et puis j'avais très bien il a
aussi dû se faire opérer à coeur ouvert
en 2014 il est aujourd'hui en pleine
santé elodie avec un clin d'oeil que son
oncle napoléon a vécu jusqu'à 106 ans
emilien vallée croit dur comme fer qu'il
ne sera jamais trop vieux pour jouer au
tennis
et si antoine est fière du canada
brossard